merci Loïc Hervé nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure
sénateur de la haute-savoiement du
groupe Union centrée sont va bien sûr
parler de votre département dans
quelques instants et de l'avenir des
stations de ski c'est un sujet
évidemment que vous suivez mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est cette réforme des
retraites Elisabeth Bank qui a donc
déclenché hier après-midi le 49-3 dans
une ambiance de chahut à l'Assemblée
nationale on a vu une partie de la nuque
qui chantait la Marseillaise des députés
RN qui tapaient sur leur public et
Elisabeth band c'est dit très choqué par
l'ambiance pendant son discours
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cette
scène c'est une image du de la vie
politique et du Parlement qui est très
mauvaise c'est le centième 49 alinéa 3
de la l'histoire la 5e République et
elle se recourt à cet article qui existe
se fait dans un climat social et
politique qui est extrêmement détérioré
donc les images alors après il faut ce
qu'il faut dire qu'on est choqué
oui ces images ne sont pas bonnes
maintenant il s'agit en urgence de de
renouer le dialogue dans le pays parce
que on pourra pas
continuer comme ça on en est au début du
second mandat du Président de la
République et on ne pourra pas continuer
à avoir le 49 aligné à trois sur tous
les textes et un débat aussi dégradé au
Parlement
ça c'est un pouvoir qui appartient au
président de la République et lui seul
et c'est pas un sénateur qui va lui
surtout un sénateur centriste qui est
donné ce type de conseil mais c'est une
évidence qui a qui a un moment qui a une
nécessité de de renouer une forme de
diogue rappelez-vous les pendant les
gilets jaunes
combien de semaines il a fallu attendre
pour qu'on dise grand débat et qu'on
s'appuie sur les mers dans les
territoires pour apaiser le débat
démocratique et qu'ensuite on débouche
sur un certain nombre de décisions
politiques notamment par la loi ici au
Sénat ou à l'Assemblée nationale donc il
y a vraiment une nécessité alors est-ce
que ça peut prendre la forme d'une
conférence sociale vous savez on est au
début du deuxième mandat dans une
situation d'inflation d'inquiétude des
Français
on lance cette réforme sur des bases
différentes de celles qui étaient la
première réforme avant covid et on a
absolument pas tiré les conséquences de
la crise sanitaire sur la société
française quel est notre rapport au
travail qu'est-ce que nous voulons
proposer aux Français par rapport à
l'idée même de la retraite tous débat il
n'a pas eu lieu et on passe avec
mais c'est une c'est une succession de
mauvais choix
objectivement enfin le recours à
l'article 47 a tiré un qui est une
manière de corseter le débat ensuite
alors que c'est vrai que la gauche a
fait preuve d'obstruction c'est-à-dire
pour ça que je me suis abstenu parce que
la gauche a été à l'Assemblée nationale
mais aussi au Sénat extrêmement
contraignant dans la volonté de ne pas
aller au vote donc
cet ensemble de de mesure de procédure
qui se finissent par un point d'or par
le 49 alinéa 3 ça pose une vraie
difficulté démocratique et ce c'est une
succession de mauvais choix vraiment et
et sur un plan alors évidemment rien ne
peut justifier ce qui s'est passé hier
soir les rues de Paris des grandes
villes de France mais sur un plan
symbolique ce sont des décisions
extrêmement violentes vous le regrettez
cet usage différente toi vous aurez
préféré que l'exécutif aille au vote
quitte à le perdre
oui parce que je suis un parlementaire
et que je suis attaché au
parlementarisme et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on admette que on gagne on perd et là
on va être dans on gagne ou si on gagne
pas on gagne par la force ça n'est pas
possible dans l'état actuel des forces
politiques du pays je crois que pour
être très clair le président de la
République et le gouvernement n'ont pas
encore intégré qu'ils étaient
minoritaires à l'Assemblée nationale
donc ça ça appelle à gouverner
différemment un gouverner davantage avec
le Sénat mais aussi avec gouverner avec
les forces politiques en présence à
l'assemblée nationale le groupe LR les
formations minoritaires de la majorité
le groupe horizon le groupe modem
peut-être le groupe yote peut-être qu'on
peut enfin rentrer dans ce pays dans une
logique de majorité de projets sans
parler de coalition mais où on va
ouvrir
la manière de gouverner ça n'est
absolument pas le message qui a été
envoyé hier et c'est parce que selon
vous c'est parce qu'elle essayait de
faire le gouvernement avec les
républicains notamment il y a eu
beaucoup de concessions fait aux
républicains Elizabeth borne a
d'ailleurs pointé le responsabilité hier
dans ce 49-3 en disant c'est le texte ce
sont les convictions qu'ils portent
depuis des années et certains ne votent
pas il y a eu un travail d'amélioration
significatif alors pas l'Assemblée
nationale puisque le débat n'a pas eu
lieu mais au Sénat avec les républicains
notamment la majorité sénatoriale pour
apporter un certain nombre de correctifs
je pense au droit des femmes je pense au
carrières longues mais
la réalité je prends un exemple de
collègues députés les républicains sur
le terrain qu'est-ce qu'ils entendent
sur le terrain on peut pas demander au
parlementaire de s'enfermer au Parlement
et ne de ne rien entendre les Français
sont massivement opposés à cette réforme
donc c'est passer en force et demander
en plus à des gens qui n'ont pas été
élus en soutien de la du président de la
République et de la majorité de faire la
point
et d'assumer la responsabilité qu'ils
n'ont enfin c'est un peu fort
on se fonde sur des travaux antérieurs
ou le scénar a travaillé ces questions
là et où le Sénat est dans une dans une
optique totalement différente et la
manière dont on travaillons dans la
majorité sénatoriale dans la manière
dont d'ailleurs tous les sénateurs ou de
la même des sénateurs LR et sans tristes
travaillent c'est une manière totalement
différente de l'Assemblée nationale si
nous sommes majoritaires à l'Assemblée
Charles de Courson qui est un ancien udi
et qui est maintenant est dans le groupe
liote justement va être un peu faire de
lance une notion de censure qui pourrait
être transpartisane c'est-à-dire votée à
la fois par la nuque par le
rassemblement national vous comprenez sa
démarche c'est difficile parce que je
connais bien Charles de Courson
j'ai du mal à comprendre la stratégie en
réalité il a demandé de la démission du
gouvernement donc ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent faire tomber enfin c'est
vraiment donc oui cette motion déposée à
l'initiative de Charles Amélie de
Courson et porté par le groupe yacht
peut représenter un vrai risque pour le
pour le pour le gouvernement si la
motion de censure est adoptée elle fait
tomber le gouvernement mais vous savez
que ce qui est arrivé une fois sur le
mandat du général de Gaulle en 68 peut
se reproduire c'est-à-dire que la
réplique immédiate c'est la dissolution
institutionnellement c'est pas
automatique mais cette dissolution
si on veut faire rentrer 200 députés du
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est ce qu'il faut ce sera
c'est le risque de la solution j'aime
trop mon pays pour le vouloir est-ce que
vous vous diriez qu'on est dans une
crise politique va dans une crise de
régime incontestablement d'abord parce
que la Cinquième République est une
république dans laquelle normalement
c'est vrai qu'en 88 ça n'était pas le
cas c'est vrai que depuis 2022 ça n'est
plus le cas normalement après l'élection
présidentielle par réplique on a une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale donc
alors que la République est une
république robuste qui normalement a
prévu tous les cas de figure là on voit
bien qu'on touche les limites d'autant
plus qu'on a au sein de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale deux groupes 1 à
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite qui
sont extrêmement virulents
le RN par stratégie la moins été sur ce
texte alors qu'ils y sont totalement
opposés mais qui qui fait qu'en fait la
majorité que l'Assemblée nationale en
soi est assez un gouvernable vous
souhaitez que Emmanuel Macron retire
cette réforme
en tous les cas je sais pas ce qui dans
l'état que les choses je pense qu'ils
vont essayer quand même d'aller jusque
jusqu'à cette c'est le vote de cette
motion de censure dans le dans les
heures qui viennent en tous les cas on
risque bien de se retrouver dans la
situation de la crise des gilets jaunes
avec la nécessité pour l'exécutif de
baisser un peu le ton de revenir proche
du terrain et d'essayer d'écouter le
pays
et effectivement si on écoute le pays ça
va quand même être très difficile
d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette réforme
moi je moi je me suis absolument
c'est une réforme des paramètres de de
du système des retraites et on a tout
mis sur l'âge 64 ans et 43 ans l'âge de
départ et le nombre d'années d'annuités
de cotisations moi je suis pour la forme
du système
un peu à la Suisse mon volet pas je suis
au savoyard mais où on a un système un
premier pilier qui est un pilier
solidaire un deuxième pilier qui est un
pays complémentaire et un troisième
pilier individuel qui est une réforme de
capitalisation je sais que c'est pas
largement réparti mais il faut qu'on
essaie cette bien sûr mais évidemment
une réflexion sur la capitalisation ça a
pas été retenu dans le taxi c'est
fondamental d'ailleurs pour les pour
notre économie pour l'investissement
pour l'investissement dans les PME pour
les transitions notamment énergétiques
on a besoin de que ces capitaux là soit
en France et soit investis dans
l'économie et la capitalisation ça
permet ça c'est pas j'ai pas envie du
tout de vendre le système des retraites
à Blackrock
on va parler de votre département avec
plaisir quel avenir pour les stations de
ski avec le réchauffement climatique
jusqu'où aller pour sauver l'économie du
ski c'est les questions posées par Samir
Decher dans son reportage la fonte de
l'or blanc qui sera diffusé à 17h sur
notre antenne tournez chez vous en
Haute-Savoie et Samia nous rejoindre
[Musique]
bonjour Samia bonjour Oriane bonjour
Loïc Hervé bonjour et Samia dans ce
magazine vous êtes intéressé à l'avenir
des stations de ski face au
réchauffement climatique oui parce que
cet hiver là encore tristement démontré
Oriane la montagne est réellement
première ligne en face au réchauffement
climatique cette année encore la saison
a été très difficile on n'avait pas vu
aussi peu de neige depuis 1964 donc il y
a plein de stations qui sont restées
fermées en tout cas une partie de la
saison
la station c'est vraiment le poumon
économique de du village il faut se
rappeler qu'avant le ski ces villages de
montagne étaient souvent pauvres et
enclavé le ski a vraiment tout changé il
a enrichi s'évalé le problème c'est que
tout est centré autour de cette unique
activité et donc si elle est menacée ce
sont des milliers d'emplois qui sont
aussi derrière alors forcément on fait
tout pour les maintenir ouverte ces
stations notamment en multipliant les
canons à neige pour fabriquer de la
neige artificielle sauf que tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord et vous êtes
allé dans deux villages réalisé autour
de projets très contestés oui ce
magazine c'est l'histoire de deux
villages de Haute-Savoie séparées à
peine 30 km de stations qui ne se
ressemblent pas vraiment mais qui sont
confrontés aux mêmes choix clivant
jusqu'où aménagé la montagne pour
pouvoir continuer à skier d'un côté la
Clusaz plus de 80 km de pistes qui
culmine à 2600 mètres d'altitude donc
une station plutôt touristique de
l'autre le mont saxonné domaine beaucoup
plus modeste d'une quinzaine de pistes
qui ne dépassent pas les 1500 mètres
cette petite station elle est clairement
menacée de fermeture mais une autre
pourrait voir le jour un peu plus haut
dans le village une station de ski de
fond cette fois est envisagée sur le
plateau de Sony's c'est là qu'on vous a
suivi Loïc Hervé une partie des
habitants dont vous faites partie n'est
pas d'accord voici pourquoi
si tu es à cheval sur le mont saxonné et
la commune voisine de glyer valdeborne
se nise est un site protégé classé
Natura 2000 c'est l'un des derniers
plateaux sauvages de Haute-Savoie très
apprécié des randonneurs
là on est sur la zone de doline si vous
regardez bon ils sont remplis de neige
là mais c'est vraiment un effondrement
du sol maintenant si on crée une station
ici et ben on va s'occuper de combler
ces dolines existantes parce qu'il y en
a partout donc terrassement etc perte de
d'une richesse c'est quand même triste
quoi si on vient faire du damage avec
une machine on va tasser les sols pour
avoir des zones de tourbières qui sont
nombreuses sur le plateau qui vont être
tassés qui vont avoir leur liaison
aquatique rompue entre elles c'est un
bouleversement c'est une bombe atomique
sur un plateau
vous avez grandi et vous vivez toujours
à côté de ce plateau de sionisme qu'on
vient de voir pour vous c'est une
aberration d'imaginer faire du ski de
fond à cet endroit moi je pense que
l'aménagement du plateau de sonnisme ça
fait partie des choses qu'on doit
s'interdire en 2023 le plateau le sommet
du plateau est à 1700 mètres vous avez
vu les images elles sont tournées au
mois de janvier il y a eu la neige
depuis mais l'idée même qu'on puisse
aménager ex nihilo un ce plateau
envisager la construction d'une remontée
mécanique envisager d'avoir des pistes
de ski nordique sur ce plateau c'est une
hérésie ce plateau est un plateau
calcaire protégé au titre de du
classement Natura 2000 il est très
intéressant en soi beaucoup d'habitants
de la vallée ils vont se balader
beaucoup de touristes sont intéressés
par cet endroit il faut le protéger à
tout prix et c'est très différent ce
projet d'aménagement complètement
nouveau de mesures qui sont prises par
des stations de skiable qui elles vont
pouvoir continuer un certain nombre
d'investissements pour permettre de
prolonger l'activité de de ce qui de ce
qui est alpin comme ce que vous avez pu
voir à La Clusaz
qui sont qui sont de nature différente
donc pour ce qui est de répondre à votre
question pour ce qui est du plateau de
sonnisme non et l'opposition populaire
elle est importante parce que en fait
c'est pas une hostilité à un projet
c'est une hostilité à tout projet
là-haut il faut bien que les les acteurs
de terrain l'entendent il y a
aujourd'hui une mobilisation extrêmement
forte pour s'opposer à cela et pourtant
le président du département qui lui veut
développer le ski de fond en
Haute-Savoie assure que l'aménagement
d'un domaine nordique n'aurait aucun
impact sur le plateau on l'écoute avant
de vous faire réagir
non il y a aucun terrassement de fait
sur aucune sur aucun plateau voilà
aujourd'hui vous allez sur le plateau
des Glières en dehors des piquets et oui
d'une dameuse qui passe il y a
absolument rien le plateau de Solaison
c'est pareil le plateau des Brasses
c'est pareil la Chapelle d'Abondance
c'est pareil donc non c'est un fantasme
on n'a pas besoin de faire de
terrassement pour faire du du ski de
fond c'est pas c'est pas un passage
obligé pas de terrassement juste
quelques piquets pour faire une station
de ski de fond sur ce plateau vous y
croyez loïcard
et on dit après que dans ce projet il y
a pas de terrasse bon bref
les pistes de ski de fond en
Haute-Savoie sont très souvent sur des
pistes sur des pistes et des voiries
forestières donc avec évidemment une
emprise et une terrassement existant
qui est prêt qui est préalable à la
chute de la neige et qui permet de
évidemment de damer donc
le plateau de Sony est un plateau
naturel sur lequel il y a des
nidification de traîtra à lire sur
lequel il y a les deux lignes qui ont
été des
oiseaux protégés sur lequel il y a ces
fameuses dolines qui sont des des
éléments géologiques extrêmement
intéressants mais qui proposent des
problèmes puisque ce sont des trous et
donc affirmer comme ça qu'il y aura
absolument aucun travaux moi
je parle pour moi je n'y crois pas alors
il y a une chose qu'il faut savoir sur
ce plateau c'est qu'en hiver quand il y
a beaucoup de neige on ne peut pas y
accéder par la route donc vous et le
collectif d'opposition une de vos plus
grandes craintes c'est la construction
d'une remontée mécanique pour amener des
skieurs sur ce plateau pourquoi cette
crainte une remontée mécanique sur ce
plateau
une remontée mécanique ça veut dire à
Laval un parking pour pour stationner
les véhicules des gens qui vont utiliser
la remontée mécanique ça veut dire des
pylônes qui vont aller du de la gare de
départ à la gare d'arrivée ça veut dire
deux constructions une à l'arrêt une au
départ une à l'arrivée donc c'est une
anthropisation une artificialisation
d'un site
auquel on est attaché sur la défense
même de de l'environnement donc ce sont
des infrastructures lourdes aujourd'hui
dans les stations de sports d'hiver je
cite à nouveau la Clusaz on essaye
d'avoir des remontées mécaniques
modernes qui ont moins d'impact sur
l'environnement et on essaye d'enlever
ces vieilles remontées mécaniques des
années 70 pour mettre des remontées
mécaniques beaucoup plus
modernes et qui et qui ont moins de
conséquences sur sur le milieu
construire et encore une fois
à partir de rien construire une remontée
mécanique là-bas c'est faire un choix
qui est un choix d'artificialisation que
je que pour ma part je conteste dans cet
endroit là il y a plein d'endroits en
Haute-Savoie ou c'est remontées
mécanique sont tout à fait légitimes et
même des projets nouveaux mais là c'est
une folie
on va en parler justement de La Clusaz
parce qu'il y a d'autres projets très
compter c'est honte ça va oui notamment
cette fameuse retenue colinéaire à La
Clusaz qui est le donc le deuxième
village on a tourné ce magazine alors
une retenue colinéaire c'est une sorte
de laque artificiel qu'on va creuser
pour stocker de l'eau de l'eau qui va
pouvoir servir alimenter un village en
eau potable pour la sécurité incendie
mais là en l'occurrence à La Clusaz elle
va surtout servir si elle voit le jour à
faire fonctionner des canons à neige le
problème c'est que la mairie a choisi un
site qui est situé dans une zone humide
près d'une tourbière on a suivi les
membres du collectif qui s'est opposé à
ce projet regardez
derrière ces arbres la mairie de La
Clusaz prévoit de creuser une retenue
colinéaire de 148 000 mètres cubes soit
l'équivalent de 60 piscines olympiques
les deux tiers de ces taux doivent
alimenter les keno à neige de la station
le reste est censé fournir le village en
eau potable
alors ici on est on va dire presque au
milieu de la future retenue colinéaire
donc ici ce serait creusé de plus de 12
mètres de profondeur ici puisqu'on est
un petit peu en surplomb donc on crée
cette immense trou gigantesque donc tout
ça n'existe plus toutes ces biodiversité
tout ce qui repousse toutes les espèces
protégées sont censées avoir déménagé
avant les pelleteuses
et c'est pour ça qu'on se bat en fait on
se dit que ici il y a aucun intérêt à
saccager tout ça alors en face la mairie
évidemment n'a pas du tout le même
discours elle dit c'est une zone qui est
sans intérêt qui a été dévastée par la
tempête de 1999 et puis on a fait ce
qu'il faut pour préserver toutes les
espèces protégées et on a besoin d'une
nouvelle retenue colinéaire pour
installer plus de canon à neige et
sauver la station alors qui a raison à
vos yeux Loïc Hervé ceux qui ne veulent
plus aménager la montagne ou ceux qui
veulent à tout prix sauver l'économie du
village
mais sur ce projet là et et de manière
générale sur la création de retenue
Apollinaire en tête de bassin
hydraulique c'est une nécessité nous
avons besoin en France de retenir bien
davantage d'eau en amont de nos rivières
pour précisément s'adapter aux
changements climatiques
c'est vrai pour le potable
en première raison et notamment
Haute-Savoie on va avoir besoin de ce
type de réserve pour l'eau potable c'est
vrai pour l'alimentation en eau des
troupeaux on a en Haute-Savoie une
activité pastorale qui est liée aux
alpages et on a eu des alpages cette
année on a dû monter de l'eau pendant
l'été donc il s'agit de retenir de l'eau
pour pour donner à boire au bovin
troisième chose et en tant que président
des communes forestière de mon
département et je pense notamment à la
Clusaz on a besoin d'eau pour la lutte
contre l'incendie parce que nous avons
de plus en plus de des incendies l'été
dans des massifs où il y a énormément de
conifères qui sont calcaires donc il y a
pas de rétention d'eau possible puisque
l'eau s'en va dans dans dans la roche
donc évidemment il y a la question je
vais pas l'élude il y a la question de
de l'alimentation c'est deux tiers de
qui doivent servir uniquement c'est vrai
et et c'est et vous savez aujourd'hui
parce que il y a il y a quand même
beaucoup de mythes et quand on entend ce
qui se raconte sur la neige artificiel
la neige artificielle c'est de l'eau et
l'énergie rien d'autre de l'eau de
l'énergie il faut qu'il y ait du froid
pour en produire et aujourd'hui il y a
des stations en Haute-Savoie qui sont
très bien équipées et et c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne ce n'est que
prélever de l'eau à un instant T pour la
restituer au milieu naturel elle est pas
elle parle elle disparaît pas donc il y
a les sujets La Clusaz moi je suis je ne
suis pas en soutien à ce collectif de du
plateau de Beauregard j'échange avec les
élus de la commune de La Clusaz et avec
un certain nombre de gens qui sont
plutôt proches de ce collectif on n'est
pas du tout dans le dans le même timing
que le projet précédent puisque là on
est sur un coup qui est parti il y a
même eu des saisines du tribunal
administratif sur ce sur ce sujet donc
on est sur un projet qui est quasiment à
la réalisation absolument parce que les
travaux sont suspendus mais il y a un
recours qui est d'ailleurs soutenu par
le Ministère de la transition écologique
et qui est portée par la mairie
évidemment pour que ces travaux
reprennent alors
les années à venir et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait dans 10 ans l'eau va la neige va
reculer est-ce qu'on continue
éternellement à creuser de nouvelles
retenues colinéaires pour faire
fonctionner les stations est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas tourner la page dès
maintenant et ben on risque de vous
choquer oui je vous dis qu'il faudra
continuer de stocker de l'eau en
montagne dans les années qui viennent
les pays du nord de l'Europe le font
bien davantage que nous nous devons pour
tous les les finalités que j'ai toutes
les finalités que j'ai évoquais à voir
cette prudence là pour ce qui est pour
ce qui est pour ce qui est de la
transition
des stations de ski il on a besoin
de l'économie du ski alpin pour financer
la transition l'idée qu'on appuie sur un
bouton et qu'on arrête tout et qu'on va
transformer échanger le modèle ça n'est
pas possible donc il faut qu'on ait
qu'on profite des années qui viennent là
où c'est là où c'est possible là où il y
a une viabilité économique de permettre
par l'activité du ski alpin de financer
un certain nombre d'autres activités ce
qui est incroyable c'est que une commune
comme La Clusaz mais c'est valable aussi
pour pour ces voisins
ils sont déjà là-dedans en fait les élus
de La Clusaz ils ont déjà ils ont déjà
imaginé leur station en 2030 en 2040
parce qu'ils savent très bien que il
faut faire évoluer leur modèle mais le
modèle d'arrêt du ski comme vous le
dites de manière un peu schématique ou
caricatural c'est arrêt là demain matin
qui est voulu par assemble de milieux
d'ailleurs écolo écologiste
c'est une vision complètement
idéaliste ou tronquer de la réalité
c'est très mal connaître la structure
même de l'économie de la montagne est-ce
que vous êtes inquiet pour l'avenir de
station de ski en Haute-Savoie parce que
à la différence de nos voisins de la
Savoie nos stations de sports d'hiver
sont plus basses et pour avoir fait du
ski c'est en famille dans différentes
stations de ski cet hiver on voit on
voit on voit que les conditions de ski
au mois de au mois de février
ressemblent souvent aux cousin du ski du
mois d'avril que les chutes de neige
sont moins importantes donc il y a
urgence à changer de modèle mais
ça veut dire fermeture il y a des
stations qui ont fait des stations qui
ont déjà fermé depuis une vingtaine
d'années les stations les plus bas sont
déjà enfermées et on voit d'ailleurs
dans les endroits où elles étaient
installés qu'il n'y a plus du tout de
neige donc ou plus où on n'aurait pas pu
les maintenir donc oui il y a des
changements qui qui sont qui sont qui
sont qui sont face à face à nous mais il
faut de manière volontaire par par
l'action des élus locaux par l'action
aussi des grandes collectivités qui les
aident à pouvoir favoriser cette
transition mais elle passe évidemment
par le maintien
et du ski du ski alpin autant que ce
soit possible merci Samia merci beaucoup
la fonte de l'or blanc c'est votre
reportage et c'est avoir à 17h sur notre
antenne avec vrai pourtant le carré très
beau reportage on vous recommande